one of the paradoxes of trying to
understand our minds
is that at particular moments we need to
acknowledge that what passes through
them the ideas we entertain and the
moods we're in may have very little to
do with the workings of these minds
themselves it may for example suddenly
seem as though we have a new and very
specific take on the world we are sure
that we should leave our job say goodbye
to our partner and never see our
ungrateful children again or we may feel
that we have come to a resolute new
political certainty that society is
totally corrupt and human nature
inherently selfish and yet with
hindsight we may realize that these
ideas were not necessarily logical or
true
they were just emanations of a hard to
notice detail that we had missed out on
four hours of sleep the night before or
hadn't drunk anything since early
morning much that we think about though
it seems to be rationally founded stems
in essence from the ups and downs of the
complicated bodily envelope we're
entwined with our thoughts can
predominantly be the result of what we
had for lunch what time we went to bed
when we last sat on the toilet and how
our blood sugar level is doing this can
sound hugely insulting surely we are
wiser and cleverer than to be knocked
off course by a sugary drink or a poor
night but we would be even wiser to
follow in this regard the instincts of
all good parents of young children when
they see their toddler swiftly turning
furious touchy and jealous they know
that they are not witnessing an
inexplicable character transformation in
their formerly pleasant charges they
look at their watch make their excuses
and hurry upstairs to put the young one
to bed for an hour the mind will return
to its usual state soon enough it just
cannot hope to do so while supported by
a flagging body that's done three hours
of energetic cartwheels or ball games
with the neighbor's cocker spaniel we
should understand ourselves in similar
terms when we are filled with tragic
thoughts we should remember that there
are always dark perspectives we might
adopt
when we do so therefore it isn't
necessarily because our minds have
uncovered new and solid reasons to
despair it's just that we lack the
energy to bat away our fears and stay on
the side of life and hope
we say i'm having bad thoughts and i'm
exhausted
we should learn to say i'm having bad
thoughts because i'm exhausted
we shouldn't protest that there are ways
of thinking that are primarily the
outcome of having eaten too many
chocolates or of not having been out of
the house all day and others that are
the outcome of a brisk swim and a
handful of dried cranberries
to know ourselves never means knowing
just our minds
it means tracking the decisive ways in
which these minds are daily manipulated
by our bodies
and should before we listen to them any
further be put down for a nap or sent on
a long walk around the park
please do comment like and subscribe and
take a look at our shop for more from
the school of life